what's up guys it's Marquez from the
mkbhd channel and welcome to a holiday
collaboration giveaway so thumbs up for
that yeah so basically we've got going
on here is a little collab between
Duncan three through three oh three
fellow tech youtuber and died and we're
giving away a sort of a prize pack
there's gonna be one grand prize and one
second-place prize and this is all in
the spirit of helping you guys out with
YouTube especially during the holidays
so be sure to check out his video part
of the giveaway that'll be right there
and you go ahead and click on that and
you'll be able to view and enter on his
half now why would you want to enter
twice well one of these videos will be
selected one comment below for the grand
prize and the other video will be
selected for a comment below for the
second-place prize so what exactly are
we doing away here first prize is the
canon 300 HS it's an HD point-and-shoot
camera that's very very popular both for
vlogging and YouTube videos you're also
gonna get a four gig SD card a little
mini tripod that works very well with
the camera and you get Correll
VideoStudio Pro which is a nice video
editing suite for those of you guys who
want to get started and if you are ready
YouTube in good for you this is gonna
make you better second place prize is
the kodak play full you might have heard
of it but it's a very similar camcorder
to the one i started off with when i
first started youtube it's a 720p HD
camcorder and that will definitely be a
good beginning camera for those of you
guys looking to get started so be sure
to leave a comment down below on both of
our videos if you haven't already
subscribed to one of us or the other you
might want to do that that's just so you
can see the videos we come out with
using the materials that we use
ourselves anyway this is just i just
want to keep it short and sweet this is
a nice giveaway in the spirit of the
holidays and much more videos upcoming
especially this weekend next week and
hopefully galaxy nexus video this week
next I don't know I really want that
phone anyway thanks for watching and
I'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace